[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a mexican comedy drama film
called instructions not included
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
six-year-old valentin lives in mexico
with his father johnny bravo oh mama
johnny wants his son to be fearless and
often goes to extreme lengths to make
him that way he makes a tarantula walk
on the kid locks him in a graveyard
house throws him into an ocean and so on
over time valentin's fear of heights
insects and darkness grows rather than
going away he starts to hate his father
for putting him through all of this when
valentin grows up he is still the
cowardly guy he used to be but now he is
scared of commitment in a relationship
he has grown into a womanizer who falls
in love with a different woman every
month one of his flings is an american
tourist named julie as usual they date
for about two weeks during this time
valentin promises to spend his entire
life with her and love her endlessly ten
months after the breakup valentin is in
bed with two women when someone knocks
on the door he doesn't recognize the
woman at first but realizes it is one of
the girls who he promised to stay with
for life julie has barely a month-old
baby girl with her valentine
congratulates her until he finds out
that the baby is his julie hands the
baby to him before going downstairs to
pay for the cab valentin waits for more
than 10 minutes with his flings but she
doesn't return eventually he figures out
that she has left the child with him and
freaks out julie calls from the airport
asking him to take care of the baby and
ending the call abruptly not knowing
what to do with her valentine puts her
on a chair and runs to the airport but
then he remembers that babies aren't
supposed to be left alone and returns to
get her seconds later on finally
reaching the airport he notices julie
boarding a flight following that he goes
to his friend sammy's restaurant by the
beach julie has also left a passport
with the baby that reveals her name is
maggie sammy's girlfriend says that he
will have to take care of the baby from
now on but valentin is not ready to be a
father sammy jokingly suggests they call
angelina jolie but the other two dismiss
him after that valentin returns home
with his friends and goes through every
gift that dozens of his girlfriends have
given him somewhere in the pile he finds
a letter from julie that she had sent a
year ago but he had never opened in the
letter she reveals that she works as a
pilates teacher at a resort in la
attached to it is a picture of herself
although he has no visa or passport
valentine makes it his mission to travel
to la and hand julie her baby back while
hitchhiking to the country border he
meets a lorry driver named lupe who
offers them a ride throughout the
journey maggie doesn't stop crying
mostly because valentine has no clue how
to take care of her he changes her
diaper for the first time and eventually
starts enjoying having a daughter when
they reach the border the police do not
allow him to cross it lupe looks at
valentin in disappointment stating that
he should have said he didn't have a
visa surprisingly enough he turns out to
be a smuggler who helps people to cross
the border illegally the lorry is filled
with illegal immigrants who valentin
then joins after finally reaching the
resort that he was looking for he shows
the watchman julie's picture the man
claims that she no longer works there
and has moved to new york but since
valentine doesn't understand english he
thinks julie is inside the resort he
breaks in through the laundry room and
keeps maggie inside a basket before
going on a search for julie after being
directed to the presidential suite he
meets a famous hollywood director named
frank while talking to him valentin
notices that maggie has somehow come out
of the basket and is crawling towards
the swimming pool battling his fear of
heights valentin jumps down several
floors and saves his daughter impressed
by his courage frank offers him the job
of a stuntman several years pass and
valentin learns to be the best father to
maggie he does everything he can to make
her happy and is ready to risk his life
for her he even brings her to every
movie set where she translates the
director's orders to him to maggie her
father is a superhero every time
valentin gets injured on set he pretends
to be dead and maggie reincarnates him
he does this so she won't be worried
about him performing dangerous stunts
they live in a small apartment that is
filled with toys a slide and a built-in
wall climbing set maggie also gets to
eat whatever she wants and skip school
half of the time it is clear that
although valentine loves her very much
he spoils her even more one night we see
him secretly slip an envelope among the
mail he pretends to be surprised to see
the envelope and hands it to the little
girl the letter is addressed to her by
her mother valentine has told maggie
that her mother is a super girl who
saves different parts of the world and
hence has to always stay away from home
he has photoshopped the same picture of
julie with several celebrities and in
different places to make it look
believable maggie doesn't doubt her
father and gets super excited to receive
a letter from julie her school's
principal is mad at valentin for letting
maggie skip school so frequently he
promises to do better from now on but
the principal has heard the excuse more
than once in class maggie tells her
classmates about all the adventures that
her mother goes on they laugh and make
fun of her but nothing they say
convinces her that her father might be
lying after school the father and
daughter go to the doctor valentin
pretends to be scared of shots so maggie
would be happy to help him the doctor
gives her the regular vitamins that she
has been taking for the past four years
before prescribing valentine a pill as
well when maggie is not around he tells
valentine the medicine isn't working the
scene abruptly shifts to a few hours
later when valentin and maggie are at an
amusement park as they walk a woman
mistakes maggie for her own daughter and
then quickly apologizes the brief
encounter makes maggie sad because even
though she loves that her mother is a
super girl she still misses her and
wants to meet her valentine notices her
sadness and is ready to do anything to
get her a mother the next day he and
frank audition a bunch of women for the
role of julie frank advises valentin to
just tell his daughter the truth but
valentine is against it after an
unsuccessful day of looking for a
passable julie he returns home and gives
maggie another letter from her mother in
the letter julie says that she is coming
home soon to meet her little girl maggie
jumps on her bed and claims it to be the
happiest day of her life but then
valentine gets a call from the real
julie who now works at a law firm in new
york she says that she feels guilty for
what she did years ago and desperately
wants to meet her daughter although
valentin believes she does not deserve
to know his daughter he agrees to meet
her for maggie's happiness the next day
after the father and daughter wait for
several minutes at a park she finally
arrives she looks completely different
from how she did six years ago which
surprises valentin maggie meets her and
instantly falls in love with her as they
walk around the park valentin informs
julie that maggie doesn't know the truth
about their relationship he also asks
her to pretend to be the super girl if
the little girl asks any questions after
that the family returns home where julie
comes across all of her photoshopped
pictures and letters she is thankful to
valentin for painting her as a good
person to maggie even though she
abandoned her the next day while walking
to work valentin tries to tell julie
about something important but she cuts
him off when she turns her attention
back to him he dismisses the
conversation but seems to be distressed
about it later that day the family is at
the beach when julie reveals that she
has a lover and has arranged a meeting
for them to meet maggie the next day
valentin allows it and goes to the
meeting as well both he and maggie are
surprised to see that her lover is a
girl named renee valentin explains to
maggie that some special girls marry
other girls maggie quickly understands
and is happy to have two mothers after
spending three weeks with her julie and
renee have to return to new york before
leaving she tells maggie that her father
lied about her being a super girl and
that she is just an ordinary person in
new york maggie is heartbroken but
rather than hating her mother for
abandoning her she is mad at her father
for lying upon reaching home she takes
off all the pictures from the wall and
throws the letters away a few days later
valentin receives a letter from the
court it is revealed that julie has
filed a lawsuit to gain full child
custody in the following scene she is in
court telling the judge how bad of a
father valentine is since his work is
dangerous and he allows maggie to skip
school she thinks that her daughter will
be better off in new york with her new
family although valentine's case is also
strong because julie abandoned maggie at
a young age the judge has to make a
decision for her future not her past
after the first trial valentine follows
julie out of the court asking her why
she is doing this after he allowed their
daughter to meet and develop a
relationship with her julie says nothing
other than that she is doing it for
maggie later valentin begs frank to get
him another job that is less risky
because he wants to show the judge that
he can change frank in turn suggests he
tell everyone the truth about the
medical history that way he wouldn't
have to fight the case however for his
daughter's happiness valentin is against
the idea in the next and final trial the
case seems to be slipping out of
valentine's hands that is until he gives
a heartfelt speech about how he loves
his daughter and wouldn't survive a day
without her he also promises to leave
his current job and get a secure one for
her sake in the end the result is
announced to be in his favor julia's
furious that she couldn't keep the child
but has not given up yet the next day
valentin is with maggie at home when his
lawyer rings the doorbell he has come
with a paternity test that proves maggie
is not his daughter valentin feels
betrayed and heartbroken but he doesn't
stop loving his daughter any less
however now that he has proven to not be
her biological father julie will get
full custody a few days later she comes
to pick maggie up and sees the father
and daughter sharing a tearful goodbye
valentina asks her and the guards for
some privacy when no one is in the room
he and maggie use the climbing rope to
escape through the window using his
connections valentin takes her back to
his hometown back in la julie is furious
she complains to the police but they
claim that they cannot immediately barge
into mexico for a criminal at the same
time valentin and maggie reach sammy's
restaurant where they are welcomed with
open hearts they also visit valentine's
father's grave and several other places
that maggie had only heard about in
stories when the law is of no help julie
and renee go to frank and ask him about
their daughter's whereabouts frank
denies knowing anything but tells them a
surprising truth when they persist in
the following scene we see valentin and
maggie hanging out on the beach julie
arrives and maggie runs to hug her she
loves her dearly even though julie tried
to separate her from her father the next
few days are the best days of maggie's
life she has a lot of fun with both of
her parents then one day as they watch
the sunset together maggie passes away
in valentine's arms we then find out
that she had been sick this whole time
the only reason valentin spoiled her the
way he did was because he knew she only
had a few more years to live he couldn't
tell anyone other than frank as he
didn't want maggie to know when julie
found out the truth she was so
heartbroken that she didn't see a point
in trying to get custody in the end
maggie had a good life before passing
away subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching